hey wes
hi martin what are we billing today
well last week you showed me your
weather alerting app you said you'd like
to optimize it by pulling the values
from a cache instead of hitting an
external api every time
yeah and i read up on the new cpu
allocation controls in cloud run so
let's do that
[Music]
all right wes uh could you walk us
through your weather alerting app
yes of course when i enter a u.s state
abbreviation in this text field the app
hits api.weather.gov to get the weather
alerts for that state and then displays
them to the user
nice as you can see it's a web app and i
didn't want to maintain any servers or
virtual machines so i deployed it to
cloud run it's running pretty well
so wes i'd imagine weather alerts don't
change second by second
so is there an opportunity to cash these
alerts yeah that's a great idea martin
by cashing those weather alerts the app
can respond faster the users and our
bandwidth bill is reduced we also use up
less computing resources for our friends
at weather.gov
sounds like a win-win-win
yeah that's right so i want to cash the
weather alerts for all 50 states while i
could schedule a job with cloud
scheduler that updates this cache every
five minutes but now with cloud run and
it's always on cpu we don't have to do
that normally cloud run throttles the
cpu after your service has responded but
with this new feature we can keep the
cpu at full capacity for background
tasks like updating my cash and on top
of that we get a discounted rate too
i can see how an always-on cpu would be
useful for other things beyond updating
caches too
for example open telemetry tries to send
tracing data to the server when the cpu
is less busy
yeah that's right i mean this is useful
for go go routines uh node async calls
java threads kotlin code routines and
spring boot background functionality i'm
sold let's do it
all right well first i'll edit my cloud
run service in the cloud console
then i select cpu as always allocated
and then redeploy
wow that was easy west
yeah and now in my code i'm going to add
a loop here that updates the cache every
five minutes
and you've implemented update cache
further down in the code
yep down here take a look so i added all
of this after the standard get and post
processing any viewers who are
interested can see the implementations
in the linked repo ah looks good uh time
to deploy
yep and here goes
all right looks like it's done
i'll use the service to get the weather
loss for california now
uh-huh okay looks like we didn't break
anything uh what do the logs say
let's see well here i see that the cache
is being updated for all 50 states
outside of any requests and here i see
that the service returned a response to
you and that it was read from the cash
it's working
very nice
how much will we pay for this
well regarding costs note that we are
being billed for more time meaning
rather than just the time when instances
respond to requests we're now incurring
costs for an entire instance's lifetime
meaning from when a container is started
to when it's terminated on the other
hand we get a big discount 25 less for
cpu 24 less for memory and we won't be
charged per request fees for either
requests or background tasks i like that
uh how does cpu allocation interact with
cloud auto scaling well cloud runs auto
scaling is still in effect and may
terminate container instances if they
aren't needed to handle incoming traffic
also an instance will get shut down 15
minutes after processing its last
request unless it's kept active using
main instances once your instance gets
shut down any background work will also
get killed
in general always on cpu is good for
high and even loads or if you run run
background tasks those background tests
could be your own code or libraries like
open telemetry or spring boot good to
know thanks wes
and thank you for watching all the way
to the end if you have any questions for
wes or me about cpu allocation in cloud
run or feedback on this episode or
suggestions for future serverless topics
please let us know in the comments
bye for now
[Music]
you